voters are going to the polls in
bulgaria for the second time in three
months
elections in the spring were
inconclusive no party won enough
support to form a government this time
two parties have been running neck and
neck and opinion polls
one populist and the other pro-europe
bulgarians are confronted by
alarming revelations of state corruption
transparency international describes it
as the worst in the eu
a last-ditch effort to reach her voters
elizabeth
is a candidate for democratic bulgaria
an alliance of pro-europeans and
liberals standing a good chance
of becoming a sizeable block in these
elections
what we're first trying to do is stop
corruption because corruption in the
country is an enormous
enormous problem people are waiting for
and wanting a new government
and we'll do everything we can so what
do bulgarians want in their second
attempt at voting
i want what everybody wants less corrupt
politicians
i hope that people will grow up and get
some real change
the first thing to do is cut the
tentacles of corruption
a lot of this anger is directed against
the chief prosecutor of the country
who many hope to be a linchpin in the
corrupt networks of politicians
oligarchs and the judiciary
we finally want a chief prosecutor who
will investigate the real crimes
or not try to protect the mafia
this small protest party's program is in
its name
rise up mafia out it's part of last
year's mass demonstrations
and the will for change we have to
change
the justice system all the justice
system all the police departments
because bulgaria in bulgaria we have no
justice we have no democracy
whether that change will really come
depends on the biggest opposition party
the populist there is such a people of
talk show host and singer slavi trifanov
the polls show them on track to win
first place but their program seems
somewhat
vague and undefined we fight to change
everything we've seen in the past
how the administration works the whole
way of thinking
on the outskirts of sofia a final
pre-election meeting of the gerb
party whose boss boyco borisov ruled
bulgaria for over a decade
he's fighting a losing battle to keep
his hold on power
still his supporters seem defiant
gerb still has hopes they made mistakes
but they can fix them
because everyone makes mistakes
but it's likely that the old face of
bulgarian politics will be gone
and not see a comeback after this
election day
let's cross over now to dw correspondent
barbara basil who filed that report from
sophia
hi barbara the previous election in
april produced a fragmented parliament
that failed to form a viable coalition
will it be different this time
that is not quite sure michael and that
is the big
problem and danger in the second round
of elections because people
if it then again failed would become
incredibly frustrated however
the main opposition parties are talking
together and they
say that their best chance is to form a
minority government
and let themselves be supported by the
former communist party who is today
called socialist party
whom they don't want to form an alliance
with but who might
support their program of cleaning up the
country and of really
changing and renewing this the political
system
the opposition has a problem in so far
as their political ideas are
quite divergent and so it's not quite
quite clear what might
emerge at the end but among bulgarians
the the desire
for change the will for change is it's
really quite strong
barbara that report that we just heard
from you makes it very clear that voters
are
exhausted by having to deal with the
mafia and corruption
in the political system give us some
perspective what is the corruption
they're referring to
and how does it affect people's daily
lives
it does affect everybody all the time if
you have to go to hospital you have to
pay the doctors in order to get good
treatment
or in order to to get certain uh
certain pharmaceutical products if a
policeman stops you in the street
the best thing to do is just to pay him
some money to get rid of the charges
if you want to build something for
instance in the countryside
if you need a permit for building then
you pay the guy
in the office some money in order to get
that permit and so on and so forth so
even for
normal bulgarians this system is a
ripoff
however if you look at the bigger
picture if you look at public
procurement public buildings for
instance
if you look at infrastructure projects
and so on and so forth
the oligarchs and the mafia are
everywhere and it is as the one lady we
saw in the report said you have to cut
their tentacles
in order to really get somewhere in this
country
you have to cut their tentacle tentacles
with the corruption so deeply rooted
in the country how hard will it be for
whoever wins to
cut those tentacles as you put it
it is incredibly difficult because what
you have to do is really
root reform of the whole system you have
to put non-corrupt people in key
government posts
you have to have oversight you have to
have a judiciary that works
and and that really does sort of go
after the real crime and that does go
that's not afraid to go after mafia
bosses and of course there's always a
threat of violence
hanging over certain connections and
networks here we just have to look at
that the united states
uh to revoke the uh invoke the magnitsky
act to go after
a number of bulgarian oligarchs so it is
a
really bad situation and it will be
incredibly hard to work
to change the country but a lot of
bulgarians are willing
to participate in this that's a bubba
basil in sofia thanks much
you